Joe Biden's either lying or playing dumb
on his family's China cash Hall
Republicans have been turning up the
heat and following the money finding out
that the family was swimming and over a
million dollars from the Communist
Nation by way of Hunter Biden's Shady
Associates President Biden is trying to
play it off
[Music]
um
sent over a million dollars to three of
their family members
that's not true oh nice try but we have
the receipts to back up the first fam
got a million in cold hard China cash
and Hunters already on the record saying
he had every right to pursue the money
as Joe tries to call it Malarkey some in
the liberal media admitting this is a
big deal
there's a guy whose name is uh John
Robinson Walker he gets three million
dollars from a Chinese based company and
proceeds to wire it out to a bunch of
people named Biden one of whom is Hunter
Biden another one is a company that
belongs to the president's brother James
Biden and another amount of money to
Beau Biden's uh Widow Hallie so again
from a layperson that doesn't look good
oh we can thank house oversight
committee chairman James Comer for the
bombshell revelation and he says the
Biden family may have made as many as 11
additional business deals with Chinese
companies Comer telling Americans to
stay tuned
the White House hasn't been truthful
about this from day one I don't think
the White House ever dreamed we would
get bank records I've got bad news for
the White House this is just the
beginning we're going to get a lot more
bank records and they're going to have
to continue to backpedal and come up
with some type of reason why the Biden
families received millions and millions
of dollars from our adversaries and so
Dana what does it say now the president
has denied something his son has
admitted to well also you know last week
the White House Press Secretary took a
question from the reporters in the
briefing room they said why won't he
take questions with these Irish Prime
Minister that's a typical thing that we
do and she said oh he takes questions
all the time one he seldom takes
questions two when he does take
questions often it's while the
helicopter is in the background now
Trump could do that because his voice
carried and he also didn't play this
game like oh I can't really hear you I'm
trying to be accommodating to the Press
but gosh I gotta run so it's always
nonsense and then if they want him to
deliver a message that they would like
to maybe see in the press you can't use
it because you can't hear I mean you
have to transcribe it and then this
really Takes the Cake because the White
House has hired a very aggressive very
good spokesperson at the council's
office named Ian Sams this guy is really
good at politics he's a good spokesman
he's good if the Jad or is that a right
cross and a jab and a right cross
whatever it might be so the the
president has a spokesperson paid for it
by taxpayer dollars
in the council's office defending the
Biden family on this very issue so does
he not know about it maybe do they
decide not to tell him maybe but I doubt
it I really felt like and when he was
answering that question he's like wait
what oh my family's dealings I have no
idea what you're talking about he knows
and it's getting bigger and then just to
the media for one second I think you're
going to start seeing a lot more media
say wow this Hunter stuff looks kind of
serious and one of the reasons they'll
do that is because they don't want to
look like complete Hypocrites when they
turn the outrage up to 11 because of a
trump something that could be a
misdemeanor that we're going to talk
about in the B Block yeah what is he
going to say the bank records are
Russian disinformation judge well you
know the bidens have really relied on
what they believe is the stupidity of
the American people they are liars and
they are corrupt Joe Biden lied from the
get-go when he said I know nothing about
my sons out of out of country business
dealings and we have a laptop we have it
photographs images uh testimony and
emails that contradict all of that and
then he lies again after as Dana just
said after his son admitted that he got
that million dollars or that piece of
the million dollars uh for work that he
did and Joe Biden says well that's a lie
so you really have to look at the
president and say to yourself is he
stupid or is he lying is he incompetent
or is he a crook because both of those
all of those lies indicate something
that's very important to any prosecutor
and that is consciousness of guilt what
is the harm with saying yes my son does
business out of the country and I'm
proud of it or I don't know yeah or how
about being honest there used to be I
don't know but he engaged 51
intelligence agents to say that laptop
was this information that may have
actually been election interference and
as Dana says we can talk about this in
the B Block but this according to the
left is all a Fantastical conspiracy
theory but we are uncovering the truth
bank records what the Biden covered up
at bidens and lied about for years and
their day is coming if there are 11 more
business deals with China connected to
the Chinese Communist party then you you
don't have to think about why Joe Biden
did nothing when a spycraft went over
our intercontinental ballistic missile
sites or the fact that Joe Biden has not
spoken to Xi Jinping since that happened
or why isn't he worried that Xi Jinping
is meeting with Russia Today you know
these are these are bad people I think
this is very very dangerous and the
Americans see through it Greg what did
you make of the anchor from CNN saying
well to the lay person it looks like
this well what about to just everybody
yeah not everybody has a hunter Biden in
their family and
I'm jealous I mean it would be great to
have like a brother just gallivanting
across the globe shaking the trees for
cash you know what I mean I mean the
upside is you're gonna get a nice next
egg the downside is he might sleep with
your wife your wife's sister and perhaps
a few of the neighbor's pets so you
gotta there's always a good downside but
there's a question that that hasn't come
up yet maybe I didn't hear it but uh
were there any like if there's money
being paid there's taxes that have to be
paid was there anything ever in the tax
reforms or anything that show where
there's like I mean because that's kind
of like isn't that kind of where the Al
Capone thing ends up it's like he owed
two million million dollars that his
friend Kevin somebody paid that's that's
what I was referring to that there has
to be taxes paid on that anyway I think
it bugs me that there is a there is no
risk in the in these Investments again
this makes me jealous if I play the
stock market I'm gonna lose because I'm
stupid
you know but we're flying when we do our
investments we fly blind these are sure
things you don't always hear about like
this is a sure thing you got to get in I
invested in a bar that was really stupid
but it's amazing all of these
Investments with Hunter none were
Financial failures right they all made
money I mean he had a key to the Vault
Vault and the Vault was his last name my
last name won't even get a muffin with a
coffee you know what I mean it's it's
it's it's
you can't be that good at something you
know he just made it right now again I
am jealous and I think that what do they
call this good faith seed money is that
what they call it that's called a bribe
right yeah yeah good faith it's like I'm
giving you money for you to it's like
the reversal of hush money
yeah don't misreport the good faith seed
money you might get indicted what about
you uh this is a big Denial on the
record
it's more like an I didn't hear you and
he is letting his spokesperson do the
talking well he's like why are you
yeah there will be many iterations of
this this is going to go on for the next
couple of years
um his spokesperson has said now you're
picking on the poor Widow right that
that's where we've gone with this
um but I do think what Greg touchdown is
important when you say we don't have one
of these in every family what we did
have in every family was an addict right
that was something that you could
actually get sympathy points about with
Hunter everybody knows somebody who
struggles with addiction drinks too much
drugs whatever it may be now we're
moving into a different sector right
maybe we'll see what the results of the
investigation are but seemingly someone
who may have been taking nepotism to a
whole other level right but I I want to
say this and I understand that people
are just going to say you know why are
you talking about Donald Trump but it is
relevant for how the regular World sees
this because we're a bunch of partisans
right we're a bunch of Democrats and
Republicans and independents even have
leanings this way so Republicans speak
for yourself yeah I'm as bad as
anti-partisan as you will ever get I'm
not even in a political party I think I
haven't checked it makes you more
interesting to say that but to feel like
did I vote last time okay and yes no I
don't think I can't remember I think the
line was long Justice it's always long
because democracy is amazing
so people on the right or right-leaning
Independents people don't like Biden are
going to say this is the worst
corruption we've ever seen then people
that I talk to all the time Democrats
are saying are you kidding me Ivanka
Trump getting you know double-digit
number of patents from the Chinese the
what goes on at Trump International
Jared Kushner for her products okay so
what was the hunter product again yeah
what his consult he was advising
advising okay so listen I I have nothing
against ivanka's shoes they're fine I
guess I haven't worn them but these are
the same things people are trading on
their families Jared Kushner Jared
Kushner made two billion dollars off of
the Saudis Steve mnuchin made a million
a billion dollars as well there if you
are thinking about this objectively you
do know how it ends up and unless they
draw a straight line that Joe Biden was
padding his own bank account exactly
from this it will not matter it will be
a Witch Hunt about families just airing
dirty laundry and it will not matter to
voters which sounds familiar right yeah
well only because those are the terms
that you use for that but no but that's
another term you used with Trump for
what three or four years in this case it
looks like there's a direct line because
there are people saying they paid money
to the big man and we don't see the and
did the big man pay taxes on it I want
to know because that's amazing if he
didn't James cummer will get you well
and you know what there's 87 000 more
IRS agents that could help look into
that there you go goodness with guns I
wanna Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me
a favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now